this is a production of cornell
university
hello my name is courtney weber i am the
berry breeder at cornell university i am
an associate professor in the section of
horticulture in the school of integrated
plant science
i'm talking today from inside one of my
high tunnels in the raspberry program
raspberries being one of the crops i
work on as well as blackberries and
strawberries
the berry breeding program is one of the
original programs here at cornell
agritech when the new york state
agricultural experiment station opened
in 1882 berries were one of the original
programs and a strawberry was the first
fruit variety ever released from the
station in 1894.
in that time period we've released 44
different strawberry varieties 42
raspberry varieties and three
blackberries and these varieties are
pretty much the mainstay of much of the
new york industry and the northeastern
industries and upper midwest as well and
we see our varieties grown from
minnesota to maine
down
south into maryland
and other regions in the mid-atlantic
states so they're very popular varieties
very useful to growers and very widely
grown
some of the varieties been around for
decades
going back into the 1930s and 40s and
some varieties have been released in
recent years such as my newer varieties
dickens strawberries crimson treasure
raspberry so we're still doing new
variety development
and still supporting the old varieties
that are that are industry mainstays
as you can see behind me we have some
raspberries growing here on my right we
have blackberries in full bloom behind
me
some of we're in kind of mid-season for
that
bloom and fruit development period in
blackberries and raspberries
we will see our first raspberries
actually we saw have some in the tunnel
next to our just ripening our first
raspberries we're in the middle of
strawberry season right now
and you can see here we have raspberries
that are
in full development they're green
they'll be ripe within a couple of weeks
we see some here on raspberries that
will start blooming a little bit later
in the season and we'll have fruit into
the fall
so we ceased berry production in new
york from the early part of june the
late part of may early part of june
through
december in parts of the state and with
high tunnels that we're that we're
standing under and low tunnels for
strawberries we can really extend that
strawberry and raspberry season into
different times of the year in new york
so i work on as i said three different
species
four different species actually
but three different crops so how's that
possible so we have strawberry of course
that's its own species and we have
summer strawberries which are ripe now
and then there's day neutral
strawberries as well that produce late
in the in the season in the summer and
into the fall
in raspberry we have red raspberry and
we have black raspberry and there are
different species
both are native to this part of the
world and so there's a strong tradition
of these crops being grown and consumed
in this area
red raspberry then has a summer season
where you see the fruit developing now
it also has a fall season was where we
get flowers
in mid-summer and then fruit into the
fall
in black raspberry traditionally it has
been a summer season only
and that's one of the things that we are
doing is transferring that fall bearing
trait from red raspberry into black
raspberry so that will have two seasons
for for black raspberry as well
blackberry has never been a large part
of the program uh this the winters here
tend to be very difficult for
blackberries to survive and we see a lot
of winter damage we did have a mild
winter last year so you can see we did
get very good survival and a lot of
bloom this year but some years we see uh
up to 90 cane death in the blackberries
and we don't get any summer crop so
towards that end we're actually
working with some of the new material
mostly developed at university of
arkansas for primocane or fall bearing
blackberries as well and so to get
fall bearing blackberries that are
adapted to new york that can handle our
winters
as a plant and to handle our summers as
well oddly enough blackberries are tend
to be sensitive to high temperatures
during bloom um so we're looking for
blackberries that will bloom in the
warmest part of the year and produce
fruit in the fall before it gets cold
and and freezes
so it's a pretty mixed bag when it comes
to genetics we have the
red and black raspberries are diploid
the blackberries are tetraploid
and the strawberries are octoploid so
we're working in multiple ploidy levels
across the different species
some of the technology that we're using
in breeding first of all was the high
tunnels
seems
to be a fairly simple technology but
it's a tremendous technology when it
comes to raspberry and blackberry fruit
quality
worldwide most of the raspberries for
fresh consumption that you see in the
supermarket are grown under high tunnels
and it's to keep the rain off we're out
here today on a bit misty and windy
rainy day
and the plants are dry and the fruit is
dry and we're not getting spread of
fungus so botrytis gray mold is the most
common fungus
post harvest fungus that we see in
raspberries and it really causes a lot
of damage to the fruit and so
keeping the fruit dry
keeps the fruit from getting infected
and increases our shelf life by
two three four hundred percent
and so we're looking at instead of
having shelf life of two to three days
for red raspberries we can see a shelf
life of seven to ten days and so that
really makes a huge difference when it
comes to marketing if you're going to
grow the fruit in a concentrated area
like california for the most part
and ship them across the country
you've got to have a lot of shelf life
and we see the same thing in new york
we have a lot of rainy days in the
summertime and if we want to have good
quality
locally produced fruit we need to keep
that fruit dry and so we instituted
high tunnels in our program in 2008 we
were we produced or we set up the first
high tunnels here at agritech
and since then agritech has installed
more high tunnels to work with cherries
to work with tomatoes strawberries other
vegetable crops and now hemp
and so we're seeing
high tunnels being recognized as a very
important technology
for production and of course if you're
going to produce them
in this type of system you should breed
them in this type of system so that they
are adapted to this environment
more recently we've added low tunnels to
the mix for strawberries so we see the
same benefits for tunnels with
strawberries
as we do in high tunnels for raspberries
keeping the rain off increases the shelf
life of the berries improves the quality
raspberries are strawberries are in
full harvest right now in new york and
as you can imagine wet berries don't
store very well and so keeping them dry
until the rain passes so that we can
harvest them dry really makes a big
difference in fruit quality and so we're
breeding varieties under those low
tunnels so that they are adapted that to
that environment because the environment
is different under these conditions we
see different pest pressure
we see different insects and diseases
that can be a problem on the inside
under these tunnels than what we see in
the field and so we want to be sure that
we know what problems growers might have
and how to address them
in we also have a lab program where we
are working on various aspects of
genomics in in raspberry for the most
part
our most uh recent project has been
looking at thornlessness in in red
raspberry and in blackberry
so in red in red raspberry black
raspberry and blackberry in the wild all
the plants have thorns so the wild type
is a thorny or spiny
is a spiny cane but what you see in
blackberries is the thorns can be very
very stout
and they will penetrate your skin very
easily they're very very sharp we see
the same thing in black raspberry
very sharp thorns very stout often
they're a little bit curved
and they will stick into your skin and
penetrate your skin very easily so it
makes harvest very difficult makes
pruning very difficult it really makes
working with the plants very difficult
well in blackberry and red raspberry
there have been natural mutants found in
the wild that are spine free
and so that has been a big boon to the
industry to make spine-free varieties
because you can see as i'm handling this
cane i don't have to be very careful
they're not gonna there's no spines on
here to to cause damage and this is a
blackberry cane without thorns
and so there are natural mutants that we
have been using and breeding to produce
thornless varieties and that's really a
must especially in blackberry because
they're so so stout
in black raspberry unfortunately we
haven't been able to find any natural
mutants in the wild but you can cross
black raspberry and red raspberry and
what happens when you cross those two
species is you get purple raspberry
and so it takes some generations to get
some some black fruit back out of that
but we've been able to transfer that
thornless trait from red raspberry into
black raspberry background and now we
have spine free black raspberry canes
and our next varieties our newest
varieties of black raspberry will be
spine free
we're also transferring that that trait
of primocane fruiting into black
raspberry so we hope to have soon
black raspberries that are both
primocane fruiting so fall fruiting and
spine free as well as spine free summer
fruiting black raspberries and so that's
a pretty important trait and so what
we've been doing as well
in the lab is examining that at the
genetic level to determine what gene is
actually causing uh the spineless trait
to come through so we used a population
that was segregating for this trait
and we examined the the genome of the
progenitor parents and that's offspring
and located a region
um
in the black in the red raspberry genome
where this where the single gene for
spineless keynes uh resides and we have
several candidate genes that we've we've
identified that we think uh one of them
is actually the gene involved and so
that's where we're at at this stage
we've published some of this work
on that and we're
going to continue working on this to see
if we can actually use this gene once we
find out the exact sequence
to potentially change some of the
varieties that are already out there
using gene editing techniques into
spineless
or spine free
varieties and so some varieties that we
already know are well adapted and that
everybody
already is growing might be a little
easier to grow if they don't have spines
and so that's kind of the some of the
stuff that we're looking at into the
future for
new varieties
so one of the trends we're seeing in
raspberry around the world for
commercial production is substrate
cultures growing this the plants in bags
or in pots
to take away some of the variability of
soil conditions
in many places of the world soils are
not really suitable for raspberry and so
to have a more uniform
growing environment we're seeing more
substrate culture so what we see
around me and behind me are raspberry
seedlings actually in substrate so we
decided a few years ago that if some of
the raspberry varieties are going to be
grown in substrate we should probably be
breeding some varieties for that
environment and in that environment so
we've what we have here are raspberry
seedlings in pots these seedlings as you
can see some of them are already several
feet tall some of them are even three or
four or five feet tall
they were started from seed this year so
these plants are all of a couple of
months old so you can see how fast they
grow
raspberry seed is no bigger than a
mustard seed it's very small
but they can produce a very large plant
very quickly about 75 percent of these
plants will produce fruit this year and
so we're we're able to accelerate the
breeding process by putting them in pots
and growing them in the greenhouse
starting in february and march so that
we can have plants in the in the field
in may and actually produce fruit in
july august
and through the end of the year and so
this allows us to accelerate the
breeding process we can evaluate fruit
very quickly
from seed if we were to do this in the
open field it takes at least two years
for us to get a mature plant or we can
see fruit so in this case we've cut off
at least a year from the breeding
process
or even more because once we have this
plant
these plants are very clean in here
they're very low disease incidents so we
have a
selection that looks very promising we
can go straight to tissue culture from
this plant
and we can start producing plantlets for
trials
within months of the seed being
germinated
in the field that's a two or three year
process just to get to the point where
we might start tissue culture
and it could be four or five years and
so we can cut off multiple years from
the breeding process while also
developing varieties that might be
suitable for substrate culture and so we
have partners in new york the growers we
partner with the new york state berry
growers association association to um
to test
potential new varieties around the state
but we also have partners around this
around the u.s and around the world that
also test our new material to see if
it's suitable for different areas around
the world
for commercial production and so this is
one of the things that we instituted a
few years so we can fit about 1200
seedlings in this one high tunnel and we
can cycle through those seedlings each
year so in a three year period
where we might plant in the field those
3 600 plants we can go through 3 600
plants here in this high tunnel
in the field that would take
about four acres
to cover and in here we're doing it in
about
a tenth of an acre and so it really
reduces the amount of inputs reduces the
amount of time that we have the plants
in the field and really is increasing
our efficiency in moving through the
germplasm
one of the things that also allows us to
do is to test for some of the diseases
that we see in high tunnels that we
don't see in the field very much and so
this environment is very conducive to
powdery mildew it can be a real problem
in raspberry and so we can see powdery
mildew susceptibility in that first year
in the seedlings and eliminate those
types of germ plasms uh from our our
program and try to produce varieties
that are only resistant to pottery
mildew
you can see here some rat strawberries
you see our low tunnels it's a nice
rainy day here so you can see what why
we use them keeps the fruit dry keeps
the plants healthy you can see in here
the
the foliage is beautiful and clean
there's very little disease you can see
the fruit ripening here on the on the
plant these are seedlings in the
breeding program so these are not
varieties some of them are
pretty impressive and some of them not
so impressive that's typical
we can see some nice fruit coming off
here we're looking for in strawberry you
can see this nice pretty calyx
nice shiny fruit this one's a little uh
i don't know if you can see but the
seeds are a little sunken we don't like
that because that makes the skin really
easy to bruise
and so that's a trait we look at in
particular in strawberry
something that maybe the consumer
wouldn't really recognize we want the
seeds and the flesh to be even so that
that
you don't you can see the juice on my
fingers it's just just touching it's
enough to damage that fruit and of
course that won't pack well it won't
ship well and so that's something we
really look at you see we want good size
we want big fruit everybody likes big
fruit the pictures like big fruit
because it fills containers quickly
see a lot of color differences in
strawberry
if you look at just these three here
anything from the deep deep red to this
kind of shiny red to this pale
orange color and this is kind of what
we're seeing in the open market is that
paler color
not much interior flesh color
in the supermarket that fruit often
looks very fresh because of the
fluorescent lights the local consumer
is more
used to a darker colored berry
they see that as something that's a
little more ripe a little fresher
and that's a way we can distinguish our
local fruit from the supermarket
wholesale fruit is just by color
often texture as well our varieties are
generally softer than what you'll find
in the supermarket because they don't
have to be shipped for seven days and so
we can get away with something that's a
little bit softer it gives a little bit
better
eating experience where they get a lot
more juice in their mouth
and consumers really enjoy that fresh
local produce that comes right from the
field today maybe the same day in many
cases
and you really can't get much better
than that than a strawberry in june in
new york
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu